bonjour chez vous à l'heure de la
présidentielle bonjour à tous merci de
nous retrouver nous vous proposons une
série d'émissions spéciales nous
recevons les candidats avec les
journalistes de la presse régionale est
aujourd'hui notre invité c'est fabien
roussel bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre
candidat communiste à cette élection met
ensemble pendant une heure avec les
journalistes de la presse régionale nous
allons vous interroger sur les thèmes
qui font partie des préoccupations des
français de leur quotidien on va parler
des déserts médicaux de la hausse des
prix de l'écologie de la
désindustrialisation
d'immigration ou encore d'agriculture et
pour voir ce projet et pouvoir d'achat
de hausse des prix pouvoir d'achat
évidemment faut nous interroger si
journalistes de la presse régionale sur
ce plateau christelle bertrand du groupe
la dépêche bonjour christelle riat
nement stéphane bern est de ouest france
bonjour stéphane et en duplex depuis
leurs rédactions locales fabien roussel
même somme à nice avec denis carot de
nice-matin baptiste bis de la nouvelle
république est à tour thierry rhabiller
de paris normandie et à rouen et sophie
bardin de l'yonne républicaine et à
auxerre fabien roussel on va a commencé
en parlant de la dépendance de la
question des ehpad revenue au coeur de
l'actualité ces derniers jours brigitte
bourguignon la ministre a reçu hier les
dirigeants d'orpea qui sont mises en
cause pour des mauvais traitements sur
les résidents dans leur est pas de la
ministre a annoncé l'ouverture de deux
enquêtes dont l'une de l'inspection
générale des finances est une série de
contrôles inopinés des agences
régionales de santé dans les ehpad du
groupe est ce que les réponses du
gouvernement sont les bonnes
la colère est unanimes y compris celles
de la ministre c'est normal il s'agit de
nos aînés de nos parents de nos
grands-parents et il y à de la
maltraitance et le pire c'est de la
maltraitance pour gagner de l'argent sur
leur dos c'est ignoble cet ignoble
d'imaginer ça dans notre pays la colère
est une chose juste légitime mais il
faut passer aux actes quand il y à des
marchands de sommeil qui loge de manière
inadmissible des personnes des familles
ont les exproprie et on récupère ce
logement et on protège les familles
quand il y à des actes de maltraitance
dans des établissements comme cela on
protège les personnes âgées quant à la
france en exproprie le propriétaire de
cet établissement aux mille
établissements sous la tutelle la
protection d'un hôpital public d'un
établissement public d'un dîner d'hier
d'une structure à but non lucratif c'est
ce que vous demandez pour les ehpad
d'orpea aujourd'hui oui pour ceux où il
y assez fait caractéristique de violence
il n'est pas question que dans notre
pays qu'en france en république et biais
de des profits de l'argent fait sur le
dos de nos aînés vous demandez à
l'essieu l'état récupère la gestion des
maisons de retraite gérée par harper a
aujourd'hui non seulement il faut tout
de suite les protégés oui je demande à
l'état de protéger nos aînés dans ces
maisons de retraite où il y à des faits
de maltraitance avérée il faut le faire
parce que là il va y avoir une enquête
ils vont tourner ils vont recueillir des
témoignages
et bien qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
après ils vont dire bon c'est pas bien
faut arrêter ça bien que je sais bien
qu'il faut des sanctions mais ils sont
belles mais bien sûr qu'il faut autre
chose que des sanctions financières il
faut tout de suite processus nous nous
parlons d'êtres humains d'hommes et de
femmes qui ont plus de 80 ans
qui ont travaillé toute leur vie qui ont
même participé à bâtir la france ils
doivent être protégés orpea est géré par
un fonds en fonction aujourd'hui un des
sérieux est ce que on doit interdire ce
type de gestion des ehpad parce qu'un
fonds de pension l'objectif c'est de
gagner plus d'argent
chaque année oui il faut sortir nos
aînés des griffes de la finance on ne
peut pas imaginer un système où
aujourd'hui des fonds de pension la
canadien demain américain autres qui
viennent parce qu'ils ont des exigences
des exigences de rentabilité énorme on
ne peut pas accepter qu'ils viennent
gagner de l'argent qui doit gérer les
cellules le jour de nos aînés donc nous
disons que il ne peut pas y avoir deux
structures avec des objectifs de
rentabilité tout tout l'établissement de
personnes âgées doit être géré avec un
but non lucratif on a bien pu me fabien
roussel je suis pour créer je propose de
créer un service public un service
public chargé de la dépendance et de la
prise en charge de nos aînés je suis
pour créer je propose la création d'un
grand ministère d'état chargée des
seniors et de la mise en oeuvre de ce
plan ça fait deux mandats de président
de la république dont celui ci qui
proposait qui met sur la table une loi
et un projet pour la dépendance ça veut
dire des moyens élémentaires aussi j'ai
bien celle j'y viens il ya l'objectif
protéger nos aînés les protégés par un
service public la mise en oeuvre avec un
grand ministère est derrière les moyens
les moyens c c'est ce sont l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales qu'il le
dise il y a besoin d'au moins créé trois
cent mille emplois en trois ans pour
qu'il y ait un salarié par résident
finances a ensuite et ensuite il y a
besoin c'est ce que je propose de mettre
tous ces établissements sous service
public un grand service public de la
dépendance ça nécessite un financement
de 10 à 13 milliards d'euros et chaque
président a buté sur le financement nous
proposons nous de mettre en place le
financement de ces 10 à 13 milliards sur
le quinquennat dès la première année ah
ben il faut le l'enclencher dès la
première année mais les 300000 emplois
nous ne pourrons pas les créer dans la
première année mais nous pouvons nous
fixer l'objectif d'encre et 100000 tout
de suite donc les former ces impôts et
les cotisations sociales il faut asseoir
le financement de la dépendance sur les
cotisations sociales et donc la sécurité
sociale et on va continuer à parler des
questions de santé un mot rapidement
stéphane sur l'autre d'autres formes que
les ehpad n'y a pas que les ehpad il ya
aussi d'autres d'autres formes
originales je pense au maintien à
domicile en milieu rural et colocation
intergénérationnelle
le béguinage est-ce que vous avez un
oeil sur ce genre de choses et qu'est ce
que vous avez comme proposition
originale je parlais hier juste avant
ici avec quelques-uns d'entre vous
justement des béguinages parce que il y
en a beaucoup chez moi j'en ai
rencontrés dans d'autres départements de
france et beaucoup dans la ruralité
j'adore ces structures petit de taille
humaine qui permet à des personnes âgées
qui ont vécu dans leur village de
pouvoir y rester assez béguinage pour
ceux qui connaissent pas c'est des
petites structures avec 5 10 maisons
accolées les unes aux autres et avec un
lieu de vie commun une salle où ils se
retrouvent ils jouent aux cartes une
cuisine bon le meilleur moyen pour
développer ce type de structure c'est
d'accompagner les communes les
collectivités parce qu'on voit que dans
la prise en charge les personnes âgées
il y a le cou qui est pris en charge par
la sécurité sociale un conte qui est
prise en charge par les départements la
dépendance mais les les collectivités
quand elle décide d'investir quand elles
veulent offrir un tel service à leurs
populations elles doivent mettre la main
à la poche et c'est cher mais moi je
propose que dans ces 10 à 13 milliards
d'euros que je prévois que l'on puisse
accompagner les collectivités
de répondre aux besoins du terrain et
leur faire confiance c'est par là que
l'on trouvera les meilleures soupes on
va continuer à parler de ces questions
de santé on va parler des déserts
médicaux un an fabien roussel en valais
à tour dans la région centre val de
loire retrouver baptiste bizemont jean
baptiste merci beaucoup d'être avec nos
directeur départemental de la nouvelle
république en indre et loire et baptiste
la question des déserts médicaux elle
est cruciale dans beaucoup de
territoires évidemment il
particulièrement dans votre région
oui bonjour bonjour à vous rien n'est
pour jour à votre invité rapidement mais
ça vous le siège de la nouvelle public à
tours ce matin et j'espère que vous
serez d'accord avec moi pour reconnaître
que la région centre mal de loire est
une des plus belles régions de france
avec ses chatons bien sûr son flop à
l'essieu sa douceur de vivre et pourtant
oriane vous venez de le dire c'est l'une
des moins attractives de france pour les
médecins on ne compte que 98 praticiens
en remontrerait de loi 100 1000
habitants contre 124 en moyenne au
niveau national dans de nombreux
secteurs ruraux et urbains elle de loire
la désertification médicale est une
réalité qui a pas que statistiques et la
situation va s'aggraver à très court
terme puisque la moyenne d'âge des
médecins dans la région et 58 ans le
conseil régional a choisi le salarié 8
même des médecins qui sont installés
dans des centres santé publique comme
celui qui va ouvrir très prochainement à
saint-pierre-des-corps une ville que
vous devez bien connaître à une cité
très longtemps communiste de
l'agglomération de tours alors vous vous
proposé d'aller plus loin en autorisant
des installations des médecins dans les
zones denses que pour remplacer un
départ pensez vous vraiment que ce
serait suffisant et l'état ne
pourrait-il pas obliger les médecins
libéraux à s'installer dans des maisons
dans des déserts médicaux
merci pour votre question le centre val
de loire est magnifique tout aussi beau
que le nord pas de calais et c'était
effectivement un beau département qui
souffre comme beaucoup de départements
de déserts médicaux il y a en france 6
millions de nos concitoyens qui vivent à
plus de 30 kilomètres d'un service
d'urgences et donc c'est une
préoccupation importante pour nos
concitoyens il faut pouvoir
inciter et poussé les médecins à
s'installer dans ces déserts médicaux
c'est trop facile pour les
un médecin qui après 10 à 12 ans
d'études de choisir son lieu
d'installation et d'aller dans les zones
densément peuplées en médecins donc ce
que nous proposons c'est d'abord de
mettre en place
dès aujourd'hui on va on va pas attendre
dix ans que les médecins soient formés
pour qu'il y ait des mesures efficaces
c'est dès maintenant qu'il faut agir
c'est pour ça que nous nous disons que
quand un médecin maintenant sort avec
son diplôme qu'ils ne puissent
s'installer dans un territoire densément
peuplées en médecins que si un départ
qu'est ce que ça s'hérite ward en six
mois c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya
des cartes qui montrent que dans tel
département il y à 120000 sa course en
20 médecins surpris on va attirer des
zones il ya des hommes dans le sud y en
a beaucoup plus à part la côte d'azur il
va pas beaucoup dans le nord est bien ne
permettons pas que dans ces zones là on
puisse encore installer des médecins si
ya pas de départ en retraite donc un
départ une installation ensuite nous
voulons mettre en place un système de
bourse qui permettrait d'inciter les
jeunes à s'installer dans des déserts
médicaux par exemple nous proposons nous
d'accompagner pendant tout le temps de
leur formation dix ans avec une bourse
de 1200 euros par mois les étudiants ont
les à 1100 euros par mois par mois
chaque étudiant en échange en échange
ces étudiants on leur demande de
s'engager à s'installer et à travailler
pendant trois ans dans des déserts
médicaux ça c'est une proposition de loi
que nous avons défendues et débattu à
l'assemblée nationale et malheureusement
rejetée par les par la majorité en
marche et puis ont clairement vous
mettez fin à la liberté d'installation
des médecins c'est bien
là c'est une forme d'incitation c'est à
dire que le le le l'étudiant qui ne veut
pas de la bourse et qui dit moi je veux
aller m'installer où je veux
pourra le faire mais il se débrouille
pour payer ses études enfin enfin il est
un système de conventionnement qui
existe aujourd'hui les médecins sont
conventionnés et bien mettons en place
un système de conventionnement sélectif
pour conventionné en priorité là où il y
a des besoins alors les médecins disent
comment ça on nous empêche de nous
installer où on veut mais il ya une
situation d'urgence aujourd'hui et ce
système de conventionnement existe pour
les kinés pour les infirmières libérales
donc appliquons le pendant un temps
appliquons le pour ceux qui vont sortir
des écoles là pendant deux ans trois ans
pour repeupler en médecins les
territoires où il n'y en pas puis pour
finir il faut mettre fin à la fermeture
des hôpitaux les hôpitaux de proximité
ce qui existe il faut le protéger et
c'est pas un moratoire que le demande
c'est stop arrêtez de fermer des
hôpitaux là où il y en a bauchau obligea
à paris ces deux hôpitaux qui vont
fusionner c'est dramatique pour les
habitants de clichy qui vont voir l'opep
l'hôpital de 2,2 de bouchons qui va
fermer et d'autres en france dont voilà
ce que je propose pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux j'ai lu attentivement
votre programme vous voulez aussi
supprimer les dépassements d'honoraires
or les médecins français sont parmi les
plus mal payés en europe à ce que vous
craignez pas d'accentuer un peu la crise
des vocations qui est déjà bien réelle
aujourd'hui dans la médecine générale il
faut faire ça
en dialogue est en discussion avec la
profession le meilleur moyen c'est
d'inciter de favoriser les élus les
maires communistes ont une expérience en
la matière ils ont mis en place quand
ils en avaient la possibilité partout
des centres municipaux de santé des cms
je vais aller à champigny sur marne
d'ailleurs pour voir ce qui a été fait
dans ce domaine et c'est une manière de
répondre à cela c'est à dire d'un site
et l'installation de médecins où il ya
le thé et le tiers-payant mise en place
automatiquement
mais là aussi encore une fois je reviens
ce que je disais tout à l'heure avec les
béguinages il faut aider les communes à
mettre en place c'est pourquoi je suis
pour aider les communes accompagné les
questions
vous avez vous beaucoup de jeunes
médecins en fait qu'ils veulent aussi
privilégier leurs conditions de travail
leur qualité de vie avoir des horaires
décents pouvoir prendre des vacances est
ce que le salariat des médecins dans des
maisons de santé notamment en milieu
rural ça c'est pas une bonne bonne
formule pour attirer des jeunes alors
que vous soutiendriez ce genre de
mesures tout à fait mais en même temps
sans dogmatisme et sans dire c'est comme
ça qu'il faut faire dans toute la france
parce que c'est la seule voie parce
qu'au cas par cas en fonction des
territoires dijon parce que je le vis
moi même à saint-amand-les-eaux avec le
maire de la commune alain bocquet nous
avons réussi à faire venir quatre jeunes
médecins tout juste sorti de l'école
sans les salariés je sais que dans le
bassin minier ailleurs dans le
pas-de-calais à côté de chez moi
d'autres communes ont réussi à obtenir
des médecins en les salariés ont donc au
cas par cas nous à saint-amand-les-eaux
on a réussi à faire venir des médecins
en les installant dans des locaux dans
l'hôpital donc ils ont là une patientèle
de proximité est juste en favorisant
leur installation en prenant en charge
la commune avec la rs on prend en charge
les frais de secrétariat ils ont les
anciens médecins qui les accompagne dans
leur dans le raid et c est donc ces
jeunes médecins font le choix de
s'installer là et nous on accepte qu'il
travaille 35 heures qui faisait des
horaires donc adaptées à leur vie de
famille et dans une ville comme la nôtre
où il ya des services publics ou leurs
enfants les enfants de ces médecins vont
trouver l'occasion aussi de s'épanouir
et donc les médecins sont accueillis
dans des communes agréable à vie c'est
pour ça qui est important de soutenir
nos communes et qu'elle faisait des
services publics pour que ces médecins
soit est envie de s'installer dans ces
communes il faut le faire dans la
dentelle mais avec plusieurs
baguette plusieurs leviers pour pouvoir
proposer à ses médecins de s'installer
là bien au salon est retourné à tour
parce que bt bise à une autre question
pour vous oui effectivement il ya la
question de la répartition des médecins
mais il ya aussi la question de la
formation pour installer les médecins il
faut d'abord les former à tour le nombre
d'étudiants en deuxième année de fac de
médecine est passé de 234 à 340 ces sept
dernières années sans attendre
d'ailleurs la fin du numerus clausus ça
ne suffit pas à répondre aux besoins du
territoire lors d'abord parce que les
étudiants qui sont formés ici souvent
ils préfèrent aller faire leur internat
ailleurs et même ceux qui restent ici
faire leur internat il préfère ensuite
aller s'installer dans d'autres régions
néanmoins il ya un problème à la base
c'est qu'il ya pas assez d'étudiants qui
sont formés chaque année on manque aussi
d'ailleurs de professeurs manquent 102
rien qu'à la fac de tours pour encadrer
les étudiants dans ce contexte le maire
les républicains d'orléans la semaine
dernière c'est une question d'actualité
a annoncé qu'il voulait ouvrir dans sa
ville une antenne de l'université
désagréable créer une fac de médecine
privée avec des frais de scolarité de
plusieurs milliers d'euros par an pour
les étudiants
qu'est ce que vous pensez ce genre
d'initiatives pour répondre à la crise
réelle de la désertification médicale
moi je préférerais qu'on investisse pour
dans la formation avec des professeurs
français qui viennent former des
médecins
français pour notre pays c'est
malheureux vous vous rendez compte dans
être obligé de faire appel à une
université étrangère pour former en
france
je sais qu'il ya un manque et vous avez
raison de le pointer parce que je les ai
entendues aussi ont tout le monde il
faut faire sauter le numerus clausus il
a quasiment sauter quoique mais on
manque de médecins on manque de
formateurs et on manque même de mètres
carrés dans les écoles pour pouvoir
ouvrir des classes et formé plus de
médecins ça c'est un truc de dingue
quand même on a besoin d'investir
fortement dans la formation de médecins
et ça veut dire de mettre des moyens en
face donc faire sauter numerus clausus
n'est pas qu'une solution ça veut dire
que derrière il faut mettre des
professeurs et ouvrir des classes dans
les ch et puis pour conduire des centres
hospitaliers universitaires et qu'on
puisse en forme et je pense à la corse
parce que je vais y aller bientôt
bientôt la semaine prochaine et il n'y a
pas de chu en corse cauwet pourquoi nous
forme ton pas de médecin en corse et
ouvrir dans des perspectives à des
jeunes de pouvoir y travailler s'y
installer c'est ça que l'on doit faire
on se bat même aussi dans le pas de
calais avec ma collègue cathy apourceau
sénatrice pour qu'il y ait aussi un
centre hospitalier universitaire dans
dance est ce département densément
peuplées c'est une vraie bagarre à mener
dont vous voyez ce sont des
investissements lourds on pourra pas
travailler avec un budget constant on
pourra pas relever ce défi avec ce
budget content qu'on sent la dépense
publique elle est utile pour investir
dans la santé publique trail et fabien
ou le salon va remercier baptiste biz
pour ces questions il était à tours pour
la nouvelle république on va passer à un
notaire m'a parlé du pouvoir d'achat
avec vous cristal oui j'ai toujours lu
attentivement votre programme est il
proposé d'augmenter le smic à 1500 euros
et abaissé le temps de travail à 32
heures par semaine
est-ce que ça risque pas de coincer
notamment chez des patrons de petites et
moyennes entreprises si c'est un peu
plus compliqué de s'adapter alors
d'abord nous proposons effectivement
d'augmenter les salaires à 1800 euros
bruts 1500 euros net le bruit de c'est
important parce que ça veut dire qu'il
ya des cotisations derrière qui
financent notre protection sociale notre
système de retraite notre sécurité
sociale la santé etc aujourd'hui la
hausse des salaires quand le président
de la république en parle il dit mais
les salaires sont à 1000 1500 euros les
petits salaires parce qu'il ya la prime
d'activité il faut savoir que cette
prime d'activité s'est effectivement
c'est 200 250 euros que les smicards
peuvent aller chercher à la caf c'est
alors qu'aujourd'hui la hausse des
salaires les salariés doivent aller les
chercher en faisant une demande à la caf
scandale les femmes y ont droit que si
leurs maris ne gagne pas de trop parce
que la prime d'activité en y adroit en
fonction des revenus du foyer ce qui
veut dire que quand madame gagnent moins
que monsieur elle n'y a pas le droit
c'est inadmissible c'est encore source
deegan élite d'inégalités femmes/hommes
insupportable nous nous disons que les
salaires doivent être payées par les
entreprises la prime d'activité c'est
terminé ça coûte des milliards d'euros
quand même hein c'est nous-mêmes qui
payons avec nos sous la prime
d'activistes et tout comme en fait sont
réglables de payer comment on fait pour
accompagner les pme et les tpe les
grandes entreprises si vous m'en parlez
pas si vous savez qu'elles ont les
moyens de payer je fais référence
ibilité plus grands disons que quand
vous avez vu les chiffres d'hier quand
le cac 40 va distribuer 130 7 milliards
d'euros de dividendes de 10 vineland ça
veut dire qu'ils me font suffisamment de
bénéfices pour payer les salaires de
leurs ouvriers de leurs salariés et puis
il ya toutes ces pme tpe qu'il faut
accompagner et bien il a une série de
mesures que nous voulons prendre que je
veux prendre pour baisser leurs charges
réelles je pense charges d'électricité
et de gaz ils ont triplé quintuplé ces
derniers mois il faut baisser la facture
énergétique de ces entreprises chez les
ch'tis je baisse je suis pour bédié on
baisse de 30% déjà les taxes sur les
prix les factures d'énergie
d'électricité et de gaz allait voir que
ça va leur faire du bien ensuite les
boulangers là qui chauffent leur
baguette avec des fours à gaz
dire qu ils ont vu leur facture
s'envoler je fait baisser les
cotisations d'assurance c'est pour ça
que je propose de nationaliser axa et
enfin je vous l'annonçais si si je mets
en place une mesure forte pour les
entreprises des pme tpe c'est la
proposition d'un prêt bonifié à taux
négatifs pour ces entreprises de 200
milliards d'euros c'est une sorte c'est
comme le pge que propose l'état sauf que
nous l'état nous y mettrons 20 milliards
d'euros en plus pour que justement les
entreprises quand elles solliciteront ce
prêt bonifié eh bien elle ne
rembourseront pas la totalité
attendre à voir cette sécheresse est un
prêt à taux négatif c'est à dire que à
la fin eh bien il remporte de l'argent
c'est et il ne rembourse pas toute la
totalité du prêt est bien le patron
d'une pme ou une tpe aujourd'hui il faut
en contractant ce prêt il s'engage à
maintenir son activité a augmenté les
salaires à investir et quand on fait un
prêt c'est pour investir et nous en
échange de cela l'état nous accordons ce
prêt c'est pas ce sera une banque
publique qui le fera il n'aura pas
besoin de se mettre à genoux et de
supplier en pleurant la banque pourra
voir lettre de ce prêt et l'état
s'engage à l'accompagner mais même à
rajouter de l'argent et en lui disant ce
prêt sur deux ans trois ans vous ne
rembourserait pas la totalité nous
serons là nous pour mettre au bout et
donc c'est un prêt à taux négatifs voilà
comment nous nous envisageons
d'accompagner les entreprises de 5
milliards juste de 108 ans et fabien
roussel vous savez les origines le pge
le pge le maire avait annoncé 300
milliards et les entreprises en ont
condensé consommer sans façon donc moi
je m'en vais à ce niveau là je suis
aussi ambitieux sauf que moi
j'accompagne vraiment les entreprises
avec du prêt à taux négatifs enfin enfin
si on augmente les salaires si on
augmente les salaires si on augmente les
pensions des retraites qui sont faibles
à 1200 euros comme je le propose mais on
va libérer de l'argent dans l'économie
française le retraité qui va gagner 300
euros 2 plus il va pas planter son
pognon dans les paradis fiscaux il va
acheter de la bonne baguette de la bonne
viande du bon fromage quand j'en ai
parlé il va changer son véhicule
polluant en véhicules propres parce que
je lui propose en plus une prime à la
conversion bref on va remettre de
l'essence dans le moteur de l'économie
on va faire du bien à toute l'économie
réelle pas celle de la bourse et des
supers profits on va redonner de
l'activité à ces entreprises à ces pme à
ces tpe est les stéphanois parler on va
parler de la question des impôts de la
fiscalité oui vous rétablissez vous
voulez vous remettre de l'argent dans
les caisses de l'état voulait rétablisse
lycées lisf et tripler son montant au
mois avec un vrai fin et avec
alors ajustements à partir de quel
montant de salaire mensuel est ce qu'on
perd alignés c'est une fois vous serez
président ben ali et saive s'est pas à
partir d'un salaire mensuel ce à partir
d'un patrimoine d'un patrimoine il y
avait en 2010 est la dernière année où
nous avons payé
certains ont payé liesse f il y avait
trois cent cinquante huit mille foyers
redevables
alliès f350 8000 par beaucoup 358
millions vous savez de quel montant
était le patrimoine total de ces trois
cent cinquante huit mille foyers nous à
la commission des finances nous adorons
nous avons eu ce rapport
1028 milliards
1028 milliards d'euros 8 milliards pour
358 x y est ils paient en moyenne 4
millions 4 millions 2,2
d'impôts alors épais plus et sf une paix
plus liesse ils ont été totalement
exonérés ces trois cent cinquante huit
mille foyers ils ont combien aujourd'hui
de patrimoine on sait plus 1500 2000
milliards ils se sont engraissés
d'ailleurs faut qu'il fasse attention à
leur santé ils ont encore plus gagner
d'argent si nous on va on va demander
aux français encore de faire des efforts
quand j'entends madame pécresse dire
tout compte fait je n'augmenterai pas
les salaires parce que elle a entendu
que le medef voulait pas si c'est parce
que c'était l'objectif les augmentera de
3% et 2 3% 4 et s'invite avec ce moment
dans les entreprises les nao savez ce
que c'est une association il ya une
négociation obligatoire
il ya des salariés qui sont à 1200 1300
euros net par mois qui se battent qui
font grève pour 1 % d'augmentation c'est
12 euros il ya des hommes des femmes qui
font grève pour obtenir 12 euros de plus
par mois et on va demander à se lasser
ses comptes il ya une batterie moins
terminer c'est combien avec vous combien
la matière de quelle peut être il y est
c'est ce doit rapporter au moins par an
par an 20 à 30 milliards d'euros et ça
c'est votre pour les nacelles sont les
foyers isf et ensuite il ya la fiscalité
sur le capital c'est à dire les
dividendes vous avez vu ces chiffres
sortis hier 3 137 milliards d'euros de
dividendes distribués lvmh total peugeot
sanofi cette bande d'incapables
incapable de trouver un médecin qui
supprime des chercheurs ferme des
laboratoires et distribue des milliards
d'euros dit les agressions de rester à
100 à 200 3 3 358 mille personnes que
vous augmentez les impôts vous
élargissez l'assiette
jantes elias f il finit bien par trois
liesse et il faut augmenter
lisf est sûre cela uniquement c'est la
pensée non pour cela pour cela mais avec
un un pagne sf plus juste parce que
parmi ceux là il y avait beaucoup
d'exemption voilà il y avait beaucoup de
petites formules qui leur permettait
quand il avait un bon avocat fiscaliste
d'y échapper c'est bien simple le
rapport sur ses contribuables il est
accessible sur le site de campagne
fabien roussel 2022 point fr j'invite
nos concitoyens à aller voir un mécénat
par exemple ça permet ça permet de défis
que ça
permet de défiscaliser ça dépend de ce
que le mécénat ça peut être utile je ne
suis pas dogmatique vous voyez ce qui ce
qui me fait hurler c'est que quand on
dit qu'il faut faire des efforts qu'il
n'y a pas d'argent c'est faux l'argent
il est là il coule à flots allez voir ja
vip et téléspectateurs à les voir sur
mon site ce rapport de la campagne
indices laissent plus ni les gens
gueddafi ont testé je vais vous demander
une réponse très rapide aux questions
sur la taxe d'habitation vous avez vous
parlé de donner des moyens aux
collectivités est ce que est ce qu'il
faut leur redonner une fiscalité propre
et ce que vous restaurer la taxe
d'habitation il faut réformer
la fiscalité locale et avec les
collectivités oui ou non je souhaitais
la taille je le souhaite je souhaite
remettre en place une fiscalité locale
pour donner aux communes les moyens de
pas forcément la taxe d'habitation mais
un nouvel impôt local beaucoup plus
juste beaucoup plus juste et qui
permettent de redonner des moyens aux
communes elles le demandent et ce sera
un nouvel impôt pour les français mais
ce sera aussi la possibilité pour les
habitants d'une commune et ceux qui
l'ont choisi pour la diriger de décider
ensemble de ceux des investissements
qu'il faut faire ci a besoin d'ouvrir
une piscine de construire un théâtre
pour la culture de d'investir dans un
béguinage par exemple aujourd'hui les
communes n'ont plus les moyens et ils
peuvent même pu faire les cartes
d'identité enfin ça va bien quoi à
leonardo commune et leur donner des
moyens de prévenir la peau on va aller à
nice fabien roussel on retrouve denis
carot bonjour denis merci beaucoup
d'être avec nos directeurs des
rédactions du groupe nice matin et
donnez vous avez des questions à fabien
roussel sur l'immigration
oui bonjour fabien roussel alors je ne
sais pas si vous viendrez dans les
alpes-maritimes durant la campagne mais
il y a de grandes chances que d'autres
candidats à l'image d'eric zemmour il y
a quelques jours se rendent à menton à
la frontière avec l'italie dans ce
secteur plus de 30 mille migrants ont
été interpellés
et plus de 500 passeur arrêté en 2021 un
triste record
depuis six ans les forces de l'ordre
s'épuisent au quotidien et les migrants
tentent jour et nuit d'entrées en france
ils sont tunisiens sudan et afghans et
plus de 90% d'entre eux ont été refoulés
l'an passé est-ce qu'il faut fabien
roussel poursuivre telle quelle cette
politique de fermeté en continuant de
refuser l'entrée sur notre territoire de
ceux qui n'ont pas de titre de séjour et
en renvoyant chez eux les demandeurs
d'asile qui n'obtiennent pas de titre de
séjour
d'abord c'est un sujet européen et
j'aimerais bien que l'union européenne
et avec la france à sa tête dans les six
mois qui viennent
prennent la mesure l'ampleur de cette
question parce que la question ne doit
pas se poser seulement qu'à la france la
question le sujet de l'immigration ne
doit pas être supportée que par les
seuls pays
frontalier de l'europe qui sont
aujourd'hui les premiers à devoir gérer
ces personnes qui fuient la guerre
notamment où la misère et qui viennent
sur les côtes grecques grecque ou
à la frontière est de l'union européenne
et donc il faut pouvoir prendre ensemble
la mesure faire en sorte que chaque pays
de l'union européenne prenne sa part
d'accueil de ceux qui fuient la guerre
j'ai toujours dit que quand on est et
quand parfois même on a été à l'origine
de conflits je pense notamment à la
situation en libye en afrique du nord eh
bien on crée une guerre et c'est
monsieur sarkozy qui en a été le
responsable et derrière on dit
débrouillez vous c'est le chaos mais
c'est votre problème ce n'est pas juste
et donc où tout le monde tout le monde
un devoir d'accueil et d'hospitalité
écoutez cette belle appel qu'a lancé le
pape françois quand ils interpellent les
chefs d'état de l'union open en faisant
ambitionnait capelle de ni à l'africaine
de des carreaux à la fraternité humaine
ce que je dis moi c'est que ceux qui
notamment passent la frontière chez vous
je les vois aussi venir chez moi ensuite
dans le nord pour traverser la manche
dans des embarcations de fortune et
perdre la vie comme le drame que nous
avons vécu il ya quelques semaines c'est
terrible c'est horrible c'est inhumain
et donc nous devons créer les conditions
donc je le dis moi créé les conditions
d'abord d'abord la première chose à
faire qui est inscrit dans notre
constitution et dans la constitution de
tous les pays de l'union européenne et
de la convention européenne des droits
de l'homme c'est de mettre en place de
faire vivre le droit au regroupement
familial
il y à des familles des hommes des
femmes qui travaillent illégalement les
frontières parce qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé
les voies légales pour le faire alors
qu'ils disent ils ils ne cherchent juste
qu'à rejoindre leurs conjoints qui
travaillent en angleterre je parle pour
ceux qui viennent sur les côtes du nord
mais on les a vus parmi ceux qui sont
morts vous avez vu ces ces femmes ces
enfants qui à le rejoindre leur père qui
travaillent là-bas enfin un homme et une
femme non plus le droit de s'aimer de
vivre ensemble sur notre terre c'est ça
l'humanisme n'est pas du ressort du
gouvernement français puisque nord est
de l'angleterre mais voilà mais comment
ça c'est pas du ressort du gouvernement
français si les terres les accepte par
ab c'est du ressort du gouvernement
français de faire vivre et d'exiger de
la grande bretagne de faire vivre le
droit au regroupement familial jeu la
grande bretagne est sortie de l'europe
via le break 6 mai elle a toujours dans
sa constitution inscrits cette règle qui
est qui a été s'imposer deschamps 50 51
ans le cadre de la la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et donc
cette cour européenne des droits de
l'homme elle doit faire vivre cela il
faut être en capacité commencé pour les
côtes quand les praticiens avec
l'angleterre que je connais bien le
sujet car ce que nous avons vécu là j'ai
le chez nous à calais et les
gouvernements de l'époque
c'était manuel valls ont fait le choix
de laisser pourrir la situation pendant
des mois et des mois et puis un jour ils
ont décidé de s'y attaquer et la
première chose qui a été faite c'est
d'obtenir ne pas après l'avoir exiger
d'eux l'angleterre qui les accueillent
ce qui était à calais et qui avait de la
famille en grande bretagne des officiers
anglais sont venus pour faire le
recensement on a réglé plus de 60% des
cas comme ceux-là donc déjà en le
prenant sous ce prisme là au moins celui
là
parce que denis à d'autres questions
pour vous la légion
fabien roussel il ya aussi la question
des sans papiers qui vivent en france
qui travaille en france est-ce qu'il
faut régulariser les sans-papiers une
partie et selon quels critères
oui oui je les rencontre régulièrement
dans chacun des déplacements je suis
interpellé interpellé par des hommes
bien souvent en grève
parce que la société d'intérim qui les
embauchent les exploits qu
incroyablement des hommes courageux
travailleurs qui sont papier sans
papiers mais qui ont une autorisation de
travailler d'être exploitée
cordialement ils ont une fiche de paye
ils payent des cotisations
dont ils ne verront jamais la couleur
comme quoi ça rapporte quand on dit que
ça rapporte plus que ça ne coûte les
travailleurs immigrés là c'est concret
et payent même des impôts et pour autant
l'employeur leur dénie ne veut pas
remplir le cerfa qui leur permet d'aller
demander un titre de régularisation et
quand l'employeur le fait c'est la
préfecture qui dit non non tout content
sinon vous aurez pas vous pas et
continuer à travailler à être exploités
mais moi je vous dénigrez bien circulé
c'est honteux on met ces sommes dans une
situation ingérable
un flou juridique insupportable donc oui
ceux qui sont là et qui travaillent qui
sont qui bâtissent la france il y
participe dans le bâtiment dans la
restauration dans le nettoyage dans la
sécurité mais n'a souri qu'il a visités
ceux qui travaillent bien sûr et ils
sont aujourd'hui il ya plein de piquet
de grève ils ne demandent que ça c'est
c'est là aussi c'est une question de
dignité il faut le réaliser tendre
régulariser tous les sans papiers pas de
quotas tous ceux qui sont actuellement
mais bien sûr comment voulez vous faire
un quota personnes vont vous travaillez
mais vous non parentes vous travaillez
vous oui en fonction de la couleur
l'origine non mais enfin vous
rencontrer c'est humain derrière et
c'est mais en plus ils travaillent c'est
que c'est un besoin c'est justement vous
seriez favorable à l'organisation la
réorganisation d'une immigration en
france autour des besoins du travail
justement mais on est en regardant
filière par filière ne profite pas un
profil pourquoi revoir ou pas du tout ça
existe enfin la loi française il faut il
faut il faut arrêter de deux
d'hystériser le sujet
la loi française aujourd'hui par secteur
organisent une immigration en fonction
des besoins dans des filières d'activité
et donc il y à des visas de séjour avec
autorisation de travail qui sont
accordés après étude du ministère du
travail en fonction des besoins ça
existe c'est sûr mais bien sûr et donc
on peut le prendre sous cet angle là
mais moi je vais vous le prendre sous un
autre angle arrêtons de délocaliser nos
yeux
en france et on va régler ça parlait
dans quelques secondes on va remercier
denis carot quêter tanis merci beaucoup
donné d'avoir été aperçu juste une
question sur la police et après on parle
d industrialisation christelle oui
gerald martin recevra vendredi les
syndicats de policiers il y a énormément
de quatre suicides dans la police qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour répondre à ce malaise
mais on les écoute déjà on les écoutait
les suffit ces écoutes aujourd'hui j'ai
l'air malin mais non parce que j'ai
l'impression que ça fait cinq ans que je
suis député tous les ans tu
nous entendons un nombre de suicides
extrêmement élevé dans la profession est
une profession qui souffre donc on n'a
pas répondu à leurs attentes ce sont des
travailleurs comme les autres qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour réussir des travailleurs
comme les autres mais qui en plus donc
pas tout à fait comme les autres qui en
plus
risqué leur vie pour nous pour vous
protéger ils prennent des coups et
gilles prennent d'autant plus de coups
que quand on a un gouvernement anti
social comme celui là on les envoie au
casse-pipe contre les gilet jaune donc
ils prennent des coups sincèrement ils
ont besoin d'être protégés ils ont
besoin d'être mieux formés ils ont
besoin d'être mieux payés et ils ont
besoin de renforts humains c'est pour ça
que je propose la création d'une police
de proximité
doté de 30 mille hommes et femmes sous
statut mieux formés pour pouvoir
accompagner la lutte contre la
délinquance il y a besoin d'eux
d'augmenter les moyens d'en quête d'
enquête pour pouvoir démanteler les
trafics s'attaquer au trafic d'armes de
drogue dans les quartiers dans des
véritables ghettos et puis et ça c'est
pas la police mais ça les aidera
beaucoup il y as besoin de remettre des
services publics dont beaucoup de nos
communes c'est ce que réclament les
maires il faut faire revenir l'état à
faire revenir la république là où elle a
disparu parce que quand la république
rotules c'est la mafia qui s'ajuste et
un dernier mot pied en mai devant
l'assemblée nationale la manifestation
justement des policiers ce qui vous a
été reproché par certains de vos
électeurs l'une des revendications de
cette manifestation c'est dire que la la
justice était trop laxiste
est ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
là encore une fois je suis obligé de
rectifier à chaque fois il y avait cinq
ou six organisations syndicales qui
appelaient à cette manifestation j étais
alors demande il y avait une
organisation syndicale le syndicat
alliance qui a eu des propos anti
républicain tapant sur la justice avec
force et dénonçant le laxisme de la
justice alors que les autres
organisations syndicales ne disent pas
ça et je les ai reçus j'ai pas vrai j'ai
revu la justice a annoncé jeudi une
hausse importante j'ai refusé de
discuter avec le syndicat alliance là
dessus parce que nous sommes est
vraiment au diamétralement opposées je
suis moi pour donner des moyens à la
justice comme le disent les autres
servent les castels surtout en avance il
faut donner des moyens à la justice des
magistrats des greffiers pour que la
justice puisse faire sur les flamands ne
change rien mais il faut faire ou non
non parce que les juges eux-mêmes disent
que l le leu leu les peines existe mais
le problème c'est pas ça c'est qu'entre
le moment il ya une plainte qui est
déposé et quand elle est instruite deux
ans après effectivement ça va pas non
c'est le problème du délai et eux ils
sont surchargés dans la justice pour
pouvoir faire le travail
d'enquêté et puis depuis de juger quoi
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut aider la
justice au lieu de taper dessus comme le
fait le syndicat alliance et on va
parler d industrialisation emploi et
pour ça on va aller à auxerre retrouver
sophie bar d'un bonjour se fier
journaliste ali républicaine on vous
écoute
mais bonjour oriane bonjour madame sel
la france a perdu deux millions
d'emplois deux millions et demi
d'emplois industriels depuis les années
70 et cette désindustrialisation a eu
des conséquences très concrètes pour les
territoires qui sont concernés par
exemple dans l'yonne on à la ville de
tonnerre qui avait une entreprise une
usine thompson qui a compté jusqu'à 1300
salariés et cette entreprise a fermé au
début des années 2000 et d'autres ont
aussi fermé par la suite dans les
communes alentour et depuis la
population a fortement baissé le
territoire a du mal à retrouver un
dynamisme à tonnerre 27 % des habitants
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté et 23%
sont au chômage alors vous comment
comptez vous relancer économiquement ces
bassins de vie et faire venir les
entreprises
donc au combien je connais cette
situation et vous l'avez terriblement
bien dépeinte
la désindustrialisation du pays a
considérablement affaibli notre pays
économiquement mais aussi appauvri et
dans le même temps je pense à votre
commune à ça ça affaiblit des des
territoires entiers qui se trouve
aujourd'hui beaucoup moins attractif on
parlait de l'installation de médecins
mais ça vient aussi de ça et donc nous
avons besoin de rendre de nouveau
attractive ces territoires parce que on
y vit on y travaille et on vit bien de
son travail il faut donc
réindustrialiser la france mais il ne
s'agit pas que de le dire et entre nous
au parti communiste français produire en
france inde russie réindustrialiser la
france j'ai l'impression que depuis
georges marchais et que je me dit je l'
ai toujours entendu je suis bien content
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde le 10 mai
faut le faire or ce gouvernement compte
y appelle à la réindustrialisation mais
poursuit le grand déménagement
industriel de la france avec encore des
qui aujourd'hui délocalisent leurs
activités à l'étranger aujourd'hui
encore il ya des salariés qui luttent
pour maintenir leur emploi parce que
leur usine a décidé de fermer gel des
loyers session ça vient c'est un bon
bloc toute délocalisation en interne on
dit aujourd'hui moi je suis bachoo
président de la république jeune homme
un vrai ministre de l'économie et de
l'industrie et je demande que tous les
projets aujourd'hui à l'ordre du jour
dans les tribunaux de commerce dans les
territoires tous ces projets sont
bloqués parce que c'est encore l'état
qui autorise un ps un plan un plan de
l'économie non parce que bruno le maire
fait des grands discours mais ils
brassent beaucoup de vent et il y a
encore aujourd'hui des entreprises qui
suppriment des pans entiers dont toi je
pense à je pense à thales je pense aux
fonderies dans l'automobile je pense je
pense à ce que j'ai vu là dans les
dernières semaines il y encore des logs
délocalisations il faut dire non dans le
nord comme le président de la république
qui est il annonce une création d' usine
attaquer mais la française et ce qu'il
dit ce matin d'un est une heure mais la
france avait 4000 emplois à la clé f va
quand même la preuve il ya une réussite
vous appelez la france israël
gouvernants et puis la française de
mécanique est appelé à fermer ses portes
dans les deux ans qui viennent et nous
ne le voulons pas bridgestone a été
délocalisée en hongrie on a perdu 900
emplois bref moi je dis stop donc l'idée
entrait bien il madame l'a très bien dit
deux millions et demi d'emplois
supprimés depuis les années 70 il y a
donc une hémorragie d'emplois quand il
ya une hémorragie la première chose que
le fond que l'on fait on met un garrot
on met un garrot bien aussi elle
derrière cette vérité risée plus les ps
non et oui mais si c'était que ça après
y'a plus personne qui va venir en france
entièrement de monde donc on met un
garrot on se met tous autour de la table
on étudie chaque situation et on fait
tout pour préserver les compétences les
machines on regarde comment on maintient
l'activité on met la pression sur les
donneurs d'ordre car comment
donneurs d'ordres jolie la pression
parce que la réindustrialisation ça se
décrète pas est ce que ça veut dire que
vous revenez à une économie dirigée et
planifier une économie nationalisation
une économie dirigée et planifiée
j'assume pleinement parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a laissé l'économie
pour renationaliser incertaine
entreprises n'aiment pas qu'on leur
organisation on a laissé complètement
l'économie entre les mains du capital de
grands groupes qui ne sont même pas
français des fonds de pension américains
ils ont leur siège ou là bas aux états
unis ou à tokyo et qui devient pas
qu'ils se font aujourd'hui de nous
donc je vous dis les donneurs d'ordre
d'abord entre une grande responsabilité
et nous en avons en france dans les
grandes filières meriem dans
l'automobile peugeot et renault l'état
est actionnaire ou directement ou via la
bpi donc on a notre mot à dire part
nationaliser on est dans lequel sera
géré mambé les autres une responsabilité
il ôte une responsabilité et derrière il
ya toute une chaîne de commandement mais
je peux vous dire la même chose dans
d'autres filières dans le ferroviaire
alstom qui a mangé bombardier comment on
fait pour que alstom au lieu de passer
des commandes de câbles électriques en
afrique du nord ou ailleurs passé
commande en france comme en deux lieux
de délocaliser la soudry la soudry je le
les points de soudure à l'étranger et
puis d'ailleurs ça revient mal fait pour
que l'on investisse dans la formation
qu'on ait des soudeurs en france et qu
on soude en france donc c'est une
question de volonté politique de moyens
politiques il faut reprendre la main sur
l'économie dont il peut nous devons
intervenir dans le capital des grandes
entreprises pas en nationalisant mais en
étant présente parce qu on va retourner
avec la scala des caisses du pays le
film avec une prise de participation
dans le temps et il faut donner des
pouvoirs aux salariés qu'ils
interviennent dans les conseils
d'administration moi je supprime la loi
y compris je supprime les ordonnances
macron et je donne des pouvoir nouveau
aux salariés dans les comités
d'établissement pour qu'il puisse dire
là la délocalisation c'est pas juste on
peut faire comme ça monsieur le
directeur et on va faire comme ça et
nous l'état on va soutenir les salariés
voulaient aller on retourne à auxerre
fabien roussel on va écouter sophie bar
d'un cas une autre question pour vous
oui parce que vous venez de le dire
effectivement il ya encore des
délocalisations aujourd'hui on a un cas
très précis dans l'yonne on a le groupe
bente l'air qui a eu un site donc de
sous traitance automobile à migennes qui
a annoncé vouloir fermer le site et qui
compte 400 salariés alors les pouvoirs
publics se sont mobilisés pour faire
contre cette fermeture mais en fait sans
repreneur l'état s'avère impuissant donc
comment comment est-ce qu'on peut
restaurer cette marche de manas alors
qu'est ce que vous allez dire aux
salariés de bentelha d'abord
je crois avoir vu dans la presse pour
avoir suivi ça j'ai pas été interpellé
directement mais j'ai cru dire qu'il y
avait eu un repreneur et qu'ils
n'avaient pas été suivies et donc bon à
regarder pourquoi mais il y a eu un
repreneur ensuite nous sommes là dans la
filière automobile
ils ont donc des compétences les hommes
et les femmes qui travaillent dans cette
entreprise il devait produire des pièces
pour les constructeurs peugeot ces
lentilles et renault donc comment nous
agissons avec ses constructeurs pour que
peugeot et renault s'engage auprès d'un
repreneur pour maintenir les savoir
faire ce qu'il ya de terrible
si on laisse faire si on laisse bentley
refermer son site c'est que derrière en
plus du chômage de la casse sociale que
c'est nous qui payons quand même un nou
lé la commune
gène c'est les commerçants qui vont
souffrir et settat mais on perd des
savoir faire ça veut dire que si demain
on se dit oh bah tout compte fait c'est
dommage on aurait eu besoin de gardes
conserver son usine cette usine on va la
réouvrir mais tintin on n'arrive pas
comme ça parce que les l'école et quand
les savoir faire sont partis pour
retrouver des soudeurs des mécanos des
électriciens etc mais sa progression et
c'est une problématique on retrouve sur
le nucléaire et on va en parler tout de
suite mais c'est pour ça que vous
réveiller à préciser avec ce film est
rien il y a donc l'état doit agir pour
bentley doit agir auprès des donneurs
d'ordre tels indices ou peugeot pour
offrir une perspective aux salariés qui
travaillent dans cette boîte moi c'est
ce que je ferai en disant écoutez on va
faire venir peugeot est là qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec qu'est ce qu'ils
produisent et est-ce que ça commence et
utile à la filière et il faut investir
et ça c'est en france dans la formation
la formation professionnelle je veux
redonner des moyens à nos lycées pour
qu'ils puissent investir dans de vraies
filières industrielles
on peut pas dire qu'on va rien du sri
alizés la france sans former des
soudeurs des électro des mécanos des
chaudronniers on en a besoin bon dieu
aujourd'hui on n'en trouve pas je
rencontre des patrons avec qui je
discute qui me disent je suis obligé de
faire venir des soudeurs du portugal
parce que j'en trouve pas en france mais
c'est un truc de dingue ils sont payer
2000 euros les soudeurs 2000 à 2500
euros tu es l'argent en plus les patrons
sont prêts le met sur la table mais on
les trouve pas mes formes 11 ans mais
dans tous les lycées et pas à la demande
quand il ya une boîte qui qui on cherche
15 hommes ont fait appel au cfa et on
fait mais c'est la problématique sur le
nucléaire on va en reparler on va
remercier sophie bar d'un merci sophy
avec nous depuis auxerre ce fils de
l'yonne républicaine et de serre en vain
à rouen normandie justement parlé de
cette question du nucléaire on trouve
thierry rhabiller bonjour thierry
rédacteur en chef et de son pari
normandie on va parler avec vous de la
question du nucléaire
c'est intéressant ce que vous venez de
dire fabien roussel sur la formation non
sur des métiers de chaudronnier de
soudeur et c'est un élément dans la
campagne qui vous distingue de tous vos
collègues candidats à gauche vous êtes
pro nucléaire vous ne vous en cachez pas
vous défendez le mix énergétique en
france et sur la question du nucléaire
en normandie va pas reparler en long et
en large que le père de flamanville on
est sur un retard il aurait dû ouvrir en
2012 il ya dix ans de retard on va avoir
une facture qui va sceller sûrement à 20
milliards d'euros et parmi les éléments
qui permettent d'expliquer ce retard et
cette note colossal et un problèmes de
malfaçons en permanence sur ce chantier
alors vous qui près qu'ils voulaient
continuer à développer la filière
nucléaire en france comment on fait pour
éviter ce naufrage à la fois technique
de cause de conception de ces nouveaux
équipements et comment sait-on pour
justement convaincre et les concitoyens
notamment en normandie vous êtes aussi
le défenseur des travailleurs et
travailleurs se sont aussi des pêcheurs
comment quand vous venez en normandie
vous arriver à concilier chute avant
cette cette double cette double
problématique à la fois de créer une
indépendance énergétique pour la france
est aussi permettre à tous les
travailleurs quels que soient les
secteurs d'activités de continuer à
faire leur métier
merci pour votre question est un choix
fondamental à faire à l'occasion de
cette élection présidentielle et je fais
le choix assumé à gauche et je suis le
seul à gauche à dire qu'il faut investir
dans la production d'énergies
renouvelables mais aussi nucléaire et
l'investissement et fort nous devons
investir fortement tant dans la
formation des différentes filières je
suis pour créer une filière dédiée à au
nucléaire pour former des ces apps et du
nucléaire jusqu'à des ingénieurs du
nucléaire des soudeurs il faut une
formation dédiée c'est important pour
voir construire les réacteurs à venir
dont celui de penly et c'est important
aussi pour assurer la sécurité
la maîtrise publique de la sécurité de
nos centrales nucléaires enfin c'est
important parce que si nous voulons
avoir notre indépendance énergétique
décarbonés d'ici 2050 et nous passer des
énergies fossiles il va falloir fauves
produire beaucoup d'électricité
nucléaire décarbonés et une électricité
stable c'est bien la raison pour
laquelle en normandie je préfère mille
fois investir dans deux centrales dans
deux réacteurs à penly et arrêter
d'investir dans des zones offshore sur
la mer qui vont empêcher les marins
pêcheurs de pouvoir développer leurs
activités qui vont même bousculé la
biodiversité marine et je laisse par
contre à jean luc mélenchon et aux
autres à défendre ce projet là mais moi
c'est pas du tout le mien au contraire
au contraire il nous faut investir donc
dans cette filière pour réindustrialiser
la france c'est indispensable on
n'ouvrira pas d' usine pour produire des
voitures chez nous si on a pas
d'électricité stables on n'avancera pas
les trains à hydrogène les avions
décarbonée si on a pas d'électricité
stables et en masse et puis enfin avec
tous les français qui paient aujourd'hui
une électricité qui est de plus en plus
cher si on veut baisser la facture
d'électricité de nos compatriotes mais
pour ça il faut s'en donner les moyens
et donc il faut en avoir la maîtrise et
la maîtrise sur un sur les prix sur sur
les tarifs et c'est nous qui devons
reprendre la main là dessus ce sera un
avantage compétitif important pour nos
entreprises c'est pour ça que je
m'adresse beaucoup monde économie parce
que j'y crois sincèrement que l'on peut
rien dû se réaliser à la france et 1 à
voir cet avantage compétitif qui va
intéresser les industriels oui c'est
important pour les ménages français les
délais les verts les écolos les
mélenchon tout ça ils disent on va
isoler tous les bâtiments et donc ils
paieront moins cher l'électricité mais
tintin et ceux qui ont isolé leur maison
comme moi je les fais je paye pas moins
cher d'électricité parce que si ma
maison est isolée mon électricité elle a
augmenté de 50 pour vous dire quoi
mélenchon very mentaux et non mais c'est
parce que c'est faux les gens le voient
bien qu'ils vivent oui mentent ils
vivent pas dans le même monde que nous
enfin les gens savent bien que quand on
isole sa maison aujourd'hui on consomme
moins d'électricité et c'est tant mieux
mais on paye pas moins cher parce que
l'électricité augmentent parce
qu'aujourd'hui le cours de l'électricité
et la dc sur le prix du gaz parce que
les éoliennes c'est une réalité les
éoliennes ont eu moins de vent cet hiver
et donc ça renchérit le coût de
l'électricité c'est un truc de dingue
donc c'est indispensable c'est
fondamental pour l'avenir de notre pays
que d'investir et dans la formation et
dans la construction d'un parc nucléaire
rénové pour retrouver une france forte
et indépendante juste avant de parler
des éoliennes avec stéphane aujourd'hui
c'est 70% à peu près de notre
électricité du nucléaire est ce qu on
garde cette part dans le mix énergétique
est ce qu'on la baisse je vais vous dire
il va falloir augmenter la pl la
production totale
donc c'est demain je suis pour qu'on
atteigne un mix énergétiques
renouvelables nucléaire mais avec une
production totale
beaucoup plus importante aujourd'hui la
production la consommation d'énergie en
france c'est 60 % énergies fossiles
pétrole fioul gaz et 40% en électricité
en 2050 ça doit être 100% électricité
dont vous vous imaginez bien qu'il va
falloir produire et c'est pas aller les
ailes et les éoliennes ou l'énergie
solaire qui va compenser ça il en faut
du renouvelable il faut de l'éolien il
faut du solaire on va pas envahir la mer
du nord de parcs éoliens enfin je veux
dire ça je laisse ça à mélenchon et à
jado c'est leur problème moi j'assume et
je veux un grand service public de
l'énergie c'est pour ça que je propose
de monter à 100% dans edf il reste 4
milliards à m il y avait assez de 84 de
85 à 100 % dans et ds avec un epic un
établissement public qui nous permettent
nous l'état de prendre des décisions au
service de la nation questions sur les
éoliennes alors je le dire il va y avoir
des besoins électriques enfin
électricité qui vont augmenter qui sont
énormes il faut produire les 2 vous avez
bien dit les deux c'est à dire à la fois
du nucléaire montée en charge mais aussi
le renouvelable le problème c'est que
vous avez un certain nombre de freins
que vous avez vous même évoqué qui sont
quand même très important des gens qui
ont très peur du nucléaire vous avez
aussi des gens qui ne supportent plus
les éoliennes vous parliez du parc
éolien en baie de saint brieuc vous avez
sur les éoliennes terrestres
ras-le-bol dans les hauts de france
comment on fait pour pour pour
convaincre les français les françaises
de la nécessité d'augmenter en charge
cette production est d'accepter aussi
d'avoir deux nouveaux sites de
production
qui puisse être puisse être construit
s'installer dans le paysage mais c'est
un discours que l'on doit avoir et sans
s'en faire peur aux français enfin quand
j'entends mélenchon dire qu'il va y
avoir un missile tiré de l'espace qui va
s'abattre sur nos centrales nucléaires
pour faire raser la france et le nord de
la france en parlant de la centrale de
gravelines géant de lui quoi enfin on
parle pas du nucléaire avec des propos
comme ça cc c'est pas sérieux enfin
quand même on parle de la reconstruction
de notre pays on parle de sûreté
nucléaire et donc il faut investir dans
la sûreté nucléaire dans une filière
française justement donné montrer à nos
enfants qu'ils vont pouvoir s'engager
dans des métiers d'avenir il y en a pour
plusieurs générations et ce sont des
beau métier ne plus être dépendant de
ressources étrangères dans ce domaine
avoir nos propres métiers nos propres
compétences nero sur les éoliennes et il
faudra y aller doucement le problème des
rôles et des parcs éoliens c'est qu'il
faut les créer que ça prend beaucoup de
surface il ya des surfaces où on peut le
faire sans gêner la nature où l'être
humain mais les mails et les centrales
les sens on va pas créer des centrales
nouvelles dans des terres vierges on
ajoute des réacteurs dans les centrales
existantes
donc on ne vient pas empiéter sur des
terrains nouvelle il faut expliquer aux
français le projet que nous avons mais
qui est partagé par d'autres et
notamment ceux qui défendent le
l'investissement dans le nucléaire j'ai
eu l'occasion d'en parler avec le pré la
république c'est d'investir dans des
centrales qui sont déjà existantes alors
acteur mais pas de nouvelles centrales
en fait tout à fait c'est des nouveaux
réacteurs dans les centrales existantes
6 mai en doutant même que cela soit
suffisant va vous imaginez là que dans
dix ans quand tout le monde va brancher
sa voiture électrique le soir
que la forte demande qu'il va y avoir ou
une vague de froid enfin on peut pas se
retrouver comme au texas à mourir de
froid dans notre pays donc on doit avoir
cette énergie pilotable mais la grande
différence que j'ai avec le président de
la république c'est là où on frotte tous
les deux c'est que lui il est pour
continuer de libéraliser le marché de
l'électricité
quand nous nous voulons en retrouver une
maîtrise publique lui il est pas pour
avoir un service public de l'énergie et
donc on sera toujours indexé sur le prix
du gaz ou enfin ça ce n'est pas
acceptable
nous devons avoir une vision sur les 50
ans qui viennent et en avoir la maîtrise
pour réindustrialiser notre pays je sais
comme ça qu'on retrouvera une france
force est et qu'on va donner un avenir à
nos enfants c'est comme ça que je parle
aux français quand je parle du nucléaire
c'est aussi c'est l'avenir industriel
mais c'est aussi des gisements d'emplois
énorme que nous devons développer et
dans les énergies renouvelables on n'a
pas parlé de l'hydraulique mais nos
barrages représentent 80% des énergies
renouvelables c'est surtout ça c'est pas
l'éolien c'est surtout les barrages
hydrauliques et là il y a une marge de
progression aussi ils font un plus
importante nom alors je vais pas dire
qu'on va aller alors alors non mais je
sais que beaucoup de ces barrages vont
voir leurs concessions renouvelées je ne
veux pas je m'opposerai à ce que ces
barrages la construction de ces barrages
soit vendu au privé à total ou à
d'autres ils doivent rester dans une
gestion publique bien souvent bien edf
mais chez edf et bien souvent ce sont
les enfants même de ses valets qui ont
suivi une formation et qui les gèrent
ces barrages et qui connaissent la
nature qui connaissent l'agriculture et
qui le font dans l'intérêt leur
population parce qu'ils y vivent moi je
voudrais pas que ce soit des
actionnaires de total qui gère à barrage
demain puis qui dit on va attendre que
l'électricité monde fort pour lâcher les
haut
et fort la saison parce que la terre on
a besoin dernière question là dessus si
on vous entend fabien au sel aujourd'hui
les verts et mène une politique
écologique n'est pas une écologie du
réel qui n'est pas proche de ce que
vivent les gens dans leur quotidien
c'est ça que vous êtes une écologie
punitive
moi je me bats pour protéger la qualité
de l'air et contre la pollution mais je
ne veux pas que ça se fasse contre les
catégories populaires et c'est ce qui
fait aujourd'hui c'est yannick jadot
fait effet une écologie anti catégories
populaires il fait une amie il
c'est facile vous savez quand on manque
de rien
de dire à ceux qui n'ont rien ce qu'il
doit faire et moi je ne veux pas que je
suis moi je connais je sais comment
vivent les gens leurs difficultés et
donc il faut les accompagner les aider
ne jamais tapé dans leur pouvoir d'achat
je sais qu'il ya quarante cinq
métropoles qui vont interdire
l'accès à leur ville aux voitures de
catégorie 3 4 5 c'est une seule vanne
sur des flux polluantes qui sont les
voitures polluantes c'est une punition
pour toutes ces familles moi je suis
pour lutter contre la pollution et faire
en sorte que les voitures polluantes ne
viennent plus dans ces métropoles mais
je 2 je mets en place une prime à la
conversion pour des véhicules d'occasion
de 10000 euros pour permettre à ces gens
à ces personnes de changer de véhicule
polluant véhicules propres pour qu'ils
aient toujours droit à la mobilité et
puis j'ai investi dans les transports
collectifs en les rendant gratuit les
verts ne veulent pas parler entendu ne
veut pas entendre parler de transport
gratuit c'est incroyable ça c'est
pourtant une aide au pouvoir d'achat et
c'est le meilleur moyen d'inciter les
gens à ne pas prendre leur véhicule et
ceux qui n'ont pas le choix permis ton
l'heure de changer leur véhicule
polluant en véhicules propres avec une
prime à la conversion de 10000 euros et
je vais même jusqu'au bout en proposant
le permis gratuit pour les moins de 25
ans parce que le droit à la mobilité
dans la ruralité c'est un portrait les
moins de 25 ans est à l'air mais elle
est dernière question de 2
terry rabier je vais y arriver à rohan
terry cet amour oui vous avez parlé de
jean luc mélenchon et notamment et
d'union parlant du nucléaire comment
vous avez pris la décision de 20 députés
quand même communiste qui est bien en
vue quand j'entends beaucoup à
l'assemblée nationale sébastien jumel ex
maire de dieppe qui défend comme vous le
nucléaire sur penly puisque c'est sa
région de choisir de soutenir jean luc
mélenchon est ce que pour vous c'est
vraiment un coup de grâce est une
trahison absolue comment on continue à
faire campagne quand on and ses
camarades quand même qu'ils partagent
beaucoup de beaucoup de décisions que
vous souhaitez mettre en application et
qui choisit à notre cheval en vue de la
course à l'elysée moi d'abord la
question sur les contradictions qu'il va
avoir maintenant à gérer vis-à-vis de sa
population qui s'opposent aux éoliennes
dans la baie de saint brieuc et qui
souhaite développer la centrale de penly
c'est à lui qu'il faut poser la question
pour savoir comment lui va gérer ses
contradictions ensuite comment j'ai pris
cette décision de la part d'un membre de
la famille puisqu'on siègent ensemble à
l'assemblée nationale c'est une décision
de sa part individuelle
qui pénalise le collectif
je la regrette mais on est tellement
déterminé motivé que quand on entend une
décision comme ça que j'ai découverte
dans la presse se faisait pas prévenu
non ce n'est pas très élégant entre nous
mais ça renforce vous pouvez pas savoir
quel point ça peut renforcer une
détermination et je sais que les
communistes de dieppe de seine maritime
sont hyper motivés pour mener cette
campagne que je porte au tour des jours
heureux je leur adresse un salut amical
mais c'est une des jeux individuels nous
savons qu'il ya deux lignes dans votre
partie entre ceux qui disent oui vous
avez bien fait d'y aller seul et ce
qu'ils disent mais ça fait deux fois
qu'on est avec jean luc mélenchon
pourquoi là on n'y va pas avec jean luc
mélenchon j'aime pas les
comment dire les par les deux lignes
parce que je suis pour le débat et je
débattrai toujours et je débattrai
toujours avec ceux qui sont pas
forcément d'accord qui auraient préféré
qu'on fasse autrement mais quand on est
dans une formation politique en discute
ensemble et on prend une décision
ensemble on l'assument ensemble on peut
continuer d'avoir des désaccords et des
débats et c'est bien normal surtout
quand on est un grand parti comme le
nôtre où il ya beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de militants d'adhérents
beaucoup d'élus dans tous les
territoires avec des situations des
approches différentes donc moi je suis
pour qu'on poursuive le débat pas
forcément construire des balles dans le
pied maintenant c'est le choix personnel
de quelques uns de faire ça ultra
minoritaire mais c'est à leur conscience
qu'ils doivent s'adresser moi je nous on
a fait un choix collectif essaieront de
la crème je vais remercier thierry
rhabiller merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous depuis rouen une dernière
question restait un mot de la primaire
populaire votre nom n'a pas été
présentée au choix des électeurs vous
avez été déçu ou c'est une voix
tellement c'est une chance est-ce que ça
pas la meilleure chose qui pouvait
arriver politiquement il se passe un
match d'abord été sélectionné dans cette
affaire je peux rien dire une chose
c'est que quand je vois ce grand
désordre
je me dis
heureusement que nous avons fait le
choix
déterminé de présenter cette candidature
pour des jours heureux en france avec un
programme clair assumer sur l'énergie on
vient d'en parler sur le travail la
richesse issue du travail je préfére
mois défendre le revenu du travail
plutôt qu'un revenu issu de l'assistance
des aides sociales comme le propose
mélenchon jadot et compagnie avec le
revenu universel qu'est ce que je suis
heureux d'avoir cette détermination et
de représenter à gauche un pôle de
stabilité pour incarner une gauche
populaire républicaine écologiste
féministe laïque et nous nous sommes
forts droit et nous irons jusqu'au 10
avril et heureusement que nous on ne
tremble pas comme unique feuille morts
et a précisé avril à vous serez candidat
aux législatives pour porter cette ligne
qui vous
candidat aux élections présidentielles
et donc si je suis président de la
république
et si donc je n'ai pas arrêté on saute
les et quand elles se présentent et donc
on en reparlera à ce moment là mais je
suis tellement amoureux de mon
territoire que je n'envisage pas un seul
instant de l'abandonner merci fabien
roussel merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin cette émission spéciale
présidentielle on va regarder vos une la
une de ouest france stéphane fin du
télétravail obligatoire le choix des
entreprises et la une de la dépêche du
midi creissels selkowitz covit le pari
de la liberté merci beaucoup merci
fabien et on va tout de suite revenir
sur votre interview avec nos clubs
[Musique]